Đối điện sự phát hành chính đối với hành vi cơ áp thành viên giả định học tập qua sức được ký vọng bảo vệ quyền trẻ em.
Sao muốn khả thì, cần khá phục tận gốc áp lực thành tích trong sáo dục.
Từ ngày 15, 2, cá nhân áp trẻ học qua sức có thể bị sự phát 5 đến mười trữ đồng, theo nghỉ định 2, 2, 2, 2, 2, 2, 2, 2,
Tuy nhiên, nhiều phủ hình cho rằng áp lực chủ yếu đến từ Yooko bài tập, lánh giá trên lớp, khiến họ bộ con phải hoàn thành nghiệp vụ học tập.
Trong bối kèng sả hội, vẫn có trọng điểm số, bằng kết, bằng thành tích tức tục tạo sự áp lớn lên học xin.
Tất chuyên gia nhận định quy định là cần thiết khi thực tế có trường gợp trẻ phản đứng tiêu cực, thậm chí bị an hưởng tâm lý, sau bị an học quả mất.
Sù vậy, việc thực thi sẽ khó khăn vì khánh nghiệp qua sức còn mang tính định tính khó trứng mình.
Hoài ra, yếu tố quanh hiện gia đình, khiến cơ quan trực năng an ngại trong sự lý.
Để quy định đặt hiệu quả, y kến chuyên gia đình y hạn sống dục 3 thiệu áp lực thi cử,
đẩy mạnh sống dục phản dịch và phối hợp trẻ giữa gia đình nhà trường.
Vũ hình cần tốn trọng năng lực xin của con, định cứ phủ hợp giúp trẻ học hiện nhận và phát triển đúng khả năng.